greetings everyone this is rob
sanders with simply learn and welcome to
today's webinar
today we're going to talk about digital
marketing tools so
fasten your seat belts and let's get
started
so what we're going to do is we're going
to take a look at some of the
best digital marketing tools ones that
are performed well in the past that are
popular
and ones that we foresee as being the
go-to tools for the future
so past present and future digital
marketing tools is the way to look at
this
uh with a good focus on a lot of
different marketing channels here
so we're gonna focus first on seo talk
about some of the tools related to on
page and off page
we're gonna switch over to paid search
talk a little bit about paid search
tools
we're going to talk about email
marketing and some of the
email marketing platforms and the tools
within those platforms
the center of it all is web analytics so
google analytics
is the tool we'll be taking a closer
look at in today's webinar
and all that it has to offer okay
affiliate marketing
we'll talk about some of the tools
available
to you and for affiliate marketing we'd
be remiss
we didn't talk about social media and
all that it has to offer and all the
metrics and tools available
all the platforms available so we'll
hone in on a couple of examples there
and then we'll also talk about some
competition
tools available for you so there's a
whole suite of tools
the one caveat being hey if you have
your favorite tool
continue using it in fact if there's a
tool that we didn't mention in today's
webinar feel free to mention it in the
comment box below this video
we'd love to hear what you're using to
manage your particular digital marketing
channel okay
and so the goal for today's webinar is
hey we hope you get something out of
this in terms of using new tools
there's some tools that i use some tools
that my colleagues use
everybody uses different tools so it'd
be good to kind of see
what else is out there so if you have
something to share share it
by all means what we're trying to do is
share what we think
are you know best practices and
some of the most popular or most used
tools out there in the industry
so that's what we're going to do the
goal is to get you to
better understand some of the tools
we're using a little bit more detail
and what we're going to do is start out
with search engine optimization
okay so search engine optimization or
organic search
we have a mixture of paid and free so
there's a lot of different platforms but
if you're focusing on
seo you certainly need to
use an seo platform so there's semrush
okay you also have google search console
which is free
so if you don't have a seo platform
you definitely need to be using google
search console and so we'll take a
closer look at that
there's google keyword planner which is
actually situated
under google ads and so if you're
running google campaigns
on google search network or even the
display network
you have access to a great tool called
keyword planner
and if you know anything about seo
you'll know that
using google's keyword planner is a good
tool so we'll take a look at that
moz is a freemium tool meaning they have
a free
trial that you can sign up for to test
drive it
but it's another seo platform and it
does cost money
got a great tool in screaming frog
that's a paid version again not too
expensive we'll talk a little bit more
about that
and then we have you know a tool in
ahrefs that help us
with all aspects of seo primarily
focusing on off page so
these are just some examples that we're
going to hone in on
but this is just a small subset of what
really is available out there in the
market
so let's go ahead and dive a little bit
deeper
and understand why we use some of these
tools well
the first reason when we talk about seo
is to find relevant keywords
not only do we want to find relevant
keywords we want to find relevant
keywords with high volume
and low competition okay we wouldn't
want to find non-relevant keywords with
high competition low volume that
wouldn't make sense so
we need a tool to kind of help us put it
all together
and so the tool of choice for us is
google's keyword planner
and google's keyword planner helps us
hone in
on keywords we may be interested
in optimizing for because not only one
are they relevant but two they're going
to have
high volume and low competition so let's
take a look
at an example in google's keyword
planner so here i am i'm in google's
keyword planner and
as i mentioned before google's keyword
planner is situated
under google ads okay so you have to
have a google ads account
to use google's keyword planner and so
when you're in google ads you simply go
to tools
and then under tools you're going to
select keyword planner
so what we want to do is look for
keywords we're focusing on organic
search not necessarily paid search
so organic search we want to
hone in on some keywords so let's just
use one of the examples that google has
given us here
meal delivery so we're gonna just type
in mail delivery
and get some results so notice i can
enter
a domain as a filter and so in other
words
hey i could say look hone in on keywords
related to this website if i wanted to
but i'm asking google hey
just give me something closely related
to mail delivery because that's my
business
so i'm going to click click get results
notice i could add another key to
it if i wanted to but i'm just going to
stick with one keyword but there are
certainly other keywords that i
can certainly hone in on if mail
delivery is
my business and so let's just hone in on
that one keyword mail delivery
we want to be found organically for that
keyword
so what google keyword planner does is
not only give us the keyword and other
keywords relevant to that
but it gives us the average monthly
search volumes
and this is an average over the course
of the last 12 months
and notice here i get a
column for competition so i'm able to
see
whether that's a very competitive
keyword or not and then just to give you
an extra
edge when you're choosing keywords you
can get a sense of what the keyword may
cost
if you wanted to bid on that for paid
search
so for mail delivery i can see it's
anywhere between
7.46 and at the top of the page high
range
16.61 so
that should alert me to the fact that
hey if i'm gonna
try and optimize for this keyword i know
it's competitive because not only google
is telling me it's competitive
by telling me high competition but i
know that the
cost per click seems a little bit high
and what is a little bit high well
you know i can see some other keywords
here that you know a dollar to three
dollars
okay i could see some other ones that
are even lower than the seven dollars
they're suggesting
so that's a indication that the keyword
is
highly competitive so the idea here
using google's keyword planner is one we
want to get an idea of what other
keywords are out there
that are relevant so it helps stimulate
some ideas for relevancy
two we can get an average monthly search
volume so we want to know on average
over the past 12 months
how many search queries i can expect
from this keyword
and then three i can get a sense of the
competition
how competitive is this keyword so if i
try to optimize for this keyword
and i want to rank for it organically is
it competitive
if it's competitive then it's probably
going to take me a bit
longer to be found for this keyword
on page one of google so that's the
whole idea behind google's keyword
planner
and note that you could change some of
the settings here so if you want to
choose a different language
okay you can hone in on a longer or
shorter period of time you can even
choose a specific location
so i chose taxes i can certainly choose
the entire united states to get
a sense of what the volume would be for
the total us
so you have settings that you can change
and manipulate
to get you the data you need to choose
keywords so that's the whole idea behind
google's keyword planner
to find relevant keywords high volume
low competition now alternatively i can
certainly use another tool
to find keywords so i have a moz account
so i logged into moz
and moz has a tool called keyword
explorer so
if i use that same keyword i used in
google's keyword planner mail delivery
i'm going to ask moz to give me some
data on that keyword
so this is for the entire united states
and again i can change that if i wanted
to okay so i can hone in
on a specific country or different
country
so what moz is telling me hey for this
keyword in the entire united states
i'm looking at anywhere from 11 and a
half thousand
to thirty thousand on monthly volume
now what moz does is they give you a
difficulty score
so a difficulty score is a score between
one and one hundred
and so i could see this is pretty much
right down the middle in terms of
difficulty
okay so if it's zero it's an easy
keyword
if it's if it's a hundred it's very
difficult
and then that means you have a lot of
competitors who are
optimizing for this keyword that are
ranking for this keyword
and so moz gives us the volume they give
us the competition
and they just like google's keyword
planner gives us
some other keywords that we can
potentially hone in on
so here i could see keyword delivery
plans delivery services etc
so i can see a lot more suggestions than
what's listed here
so moz delivers a bunch of other
analysis
related to the keyword you know they
also give you some good keyword
suggestions
so moz is a good alternative tool and
we'll be coming back to moz
related to seo for some other of its
features but for now
if you don't want to necessarily use
google's keyword planner because maybe
you're not running google ads
you can always use mazda remember moz
has
basically a freemium version meaning you
can sign up for a free account
and you can sign up for a free account
as a test trial
and you can test it for a period of days
and leverage its tools
during that free trial to get a better
sense of how these tools work
so we want to be able to use mods we
want to be able to use google's keyword
planner
not only to search for all those
relevant keywords available to you
but we want to be able to choose
keywords with high volume
and low difficulty low competition we
also want to select
primary and second keywords wisely so
remember when you
optimize you're optimizing a page for
more than one keyword
so you want to be able to have a nice
portfolio
of diverse relevant keywords with high
search volume
and low difficulty and then you want to
be able to identify those keywords that
your competitors are ranking for
so moz gives you that information and so
we want to be able to leverage the tools
available to us
to choose the right keywords so if you
need any more information on this
we got a nice webinar on keyword
research
for seo so take a look at that video
on youtube and to get more specific
details
about using seo tools for keyword
research and all about keyword research
in general for
seo so let's talk about some other
reasons
under seo what we would use some of
these tools available to us
well we want to be able to understand
the search engines
and how they crawl and index our site
okay we also want to
check the correct format of the site map
and we want to monitor
backlinks okay we also want to analyze
linking
to our web page okay which ones are good
which ones are not good okay we also
want to perform some competitor analysis
so these are some of the reasons why
other than keyword research why would we
use some of these
seo tools so we have tools available to
us some
majestic ahrefs again moz
let's take a look at google search
console
and i want to hone in on google search
console because
it is free and it's a must if you're
going to work on seo
you need to be working in google search
console
and so the whole key behind google
search console
is you have a website and you need to
get that site verified
once it's verified once school can
recognize that you
are associated with this website
then you're going to be able to see some
important information
so here i'm looking at a website and
what am i looking at i'm looking at
something called coverage under index
so what does coverage mean well going
back to what we just said we want to be
able to understand
how google's crawling and indexing our
pages
and so what google does is through this
platform
search console is they're letting us
know once they
go to our website and start crawling it
and they pull these pages back to their
server
they're letting us know if we actually
have
any issues so here i could see
i have some issues with 112 pages
and some of those issues are listed down
here so
there could be a crawl issue a 4-4
you know redirect okay so you could see
there's some five unique issues across
112 pages so here i could see submitted
url marked
new index there's a hundred of those
pages we have some redirect errors
there's seven pages that
you fall victim to this error and so we
can really hone
in on what the error is and address the
error
okay so if google's telling us hey this
is an issue
and you want that page indexed by google
then we should probably address the
error and so that's the great thing here
about going into google search console
is
you can under index go to coverage and
get a sense of what google is indexing
and what they're not indexing okay so
these are the errors
i could see they've certainly were able
to crawl
and index 9115
pages they were able to crawl okay
and they excluded 54 000 plus pages and
then we also have some pages with some
warnings
so this is kind of an overview of what
google sees when they crawl our site so
when they say crawl
they're coming to our site they're
following links on the site and every
link they follow
they're either going to index that page
or
they're going to report to you an error
or an issue that they found
if we want these pages indexed we need
to
address the issues the errors and so
that's the beauty of this report here is
google is telling us firsthand what the
issues are
so we also want to take a look at the
sitemap so
you have an opportunity to submit a
sitemap in a sitemap
is just a formatted file that includes
all your website urls
and so you're going to have this file
sitting in your root directory and
you're probably going to call it or
should call it
sitemap.xml xml being the format
so once you have this file you're just
going to let google know that that file
exists
so you're going to enter in the sitemap
url
so if it's in the root directory all
you're going to do is type in
sitemap.xml and click submit
so once you've done it just like this
site is done what google's going to do
is say hey look we see you've submitted
this and we last
read it a couple days ago and we could
see
that we discovered 1419 urls
so i can go back under coverage and i
can see
some of the issues that they found but
if i go back under sitemaps i can see
that
these are the urls they discovered via
the site map and so
the whole point of a site map is we want
to be able to
get and push the urls to google not have
google come to our site and discover
them so this is a quicker faster more
efficient way
to communicate with google all the urls
that you have on your site that you want
google to index
and so that's the beauty of search
console now while we're in search
console we might as well take a look at
some of the other features it has
and so one of the most important
features under search console
is this mobile usability report okay so
google is a staunch believer
in mobile first so nowadays most people
start
and finish a lot of their searches
a lot of their behavior on mobile so
they begin it on mobile
and they may end it on mobile so if they
don't end it on mobile then
you know perhaps they'll go into a store
or perhaps they'll go via desktop
but google is a staunch believer and
definitely a lot of what's going on
today starts
with mobile so they want you to
understand
how your site fares via mobile
and when i say fares via mobile is it
mobile friendly is it responsive is it
loading quick enough
you know is it formatted to google
standards
and so if there are any issues google is
going to let you know what those issues
are
so here i could see google's recognized
206 pages before
different issues okay so here i can see
what those issues are
just like the coverage issues we can see
specifically what they are
and so here i can see for 206 pages text
too small to read
click elements too close together the
viewport not set to device width
and then content wider than the screen
so there's 10 pages that fit under this
error and if i actually click on it
the error i can see what those 10 pages
are and so
when we're done we can actually when we
address the issues we can actually have
google validate whether the fix has been
made
so you can definitely use this as a
means of communicating directly with
google
telling google look i see what the
issues are i'm going to fix them
and then i want you to validate them
okay so this is important because if you
can
communicate with google and let them
know hey we do recognize the errors we
are fixing the errors please validate
them
you know it's going to draw google's
attention google's going to validate
them
and get these pages indexed quicker
so if you ignore the issues and the
errors especially for mobile
then you stand the chance of your pages
not getting indexed so the mobile
usability report to me is an important
report
because we want to better understand
whether google's picking up issues on
mobile
and if they are we want to address them
get google valid them so google can
index them quicker
now there's another report that is of
interest to you or may be of interest to
you
in google search console and that's the
links report so the links report
in google search console shows us what
pages
have the most links okay so here we can
see the home page has 26 000 plus
links if we hone in on interior pages we
can see the links to those pages
okay so we can get a sense of what are
the top
link pages from external links meaning
links on
other websites pointing to these pages i
can also see internal links
so google is recognizing links from
within my website from one page to
another
so external links internal links both
factors
for seo when ranking so then i can see
top
linking sites what sites are linking to
my site and then i can see top linking
text so
google search console has given me kind
of an overview of what my linking
structure looks like
okay so externally i want links from
other websites pointing to
various pages on my site and i certainly
want
my pages linking to one another on my
site and so
i'd be able to better understand what
that structure looks like
using google search consoles links
report okay there's one more report that
i think's of interest
in google search console and that's the
performance report
so the performance report is a report
that actually
you can link up with google analytics so
you can see the same
report and analytics if you're able to
link up google search console with
analytics and you should be able to do
that
all you need to do is make sure you use
the same email address
that you use for analytics and search
console so it needs to be the same email
address
you could certainly link up the two and
have this data
imported into google analytics so what
is this data that we're talking about
well it's called performance so what we
can actually see
is the queries the actual queries people
are typing
in to google so when they're typing them
into google
we can actually see how many impressions
the keyword queries received and how
many clicks the keyword queries received
and then i can see click-through rate
and average position okay so here i can
see
for this particular keyword on the first
line i could see
over the course of the last three months
it received 209
297 impressions so what does that mean
that means this keyword
was used at le or typed in as a query at
least that many times
and that's how many times my listing
appeared
in the google search results pages
based on this particular query and so as
a result
of somebody typing in this query 209 000
plus times
this site received 120 000 plus clicks
so to get a sense of the click-through
rate all you would need to do and google
can obviously do this for you
is you would simply just divide the 209
thousand two ninety seven into the one
twenty thousand
three ninety seven okay so that's really
going to give you that's gonna give you
a click-through rate
and the click-through rate in this case
is 57
so over half of the clicks occur
when this listing appears for this
keyword okay so
we can get a sense of the click-through
rate for each one okay and you could
simply just use the filtering here
now we can also see average position
okay
so we could see a little bit more than
that too we can go from queries to pages
we can go from pages to countries so we
get a sense of
how many impressions and clicks i'm
receiving by country
and importantly we can see by device
so here i can see a majority of the
people who
conduct a search related to my website
primarily do it on desktop
now i mentioned the beauty of the google
search console performance report
is that you can link it up to google
analytics and when you do that
all you need to do then is go to
acquisition
google search console and then from
there you could choose
landing pages countries devices or
queries
so i can see the same data that i see in
search console but this time i'm looking
at it
in google analytics and so here i can
see where my search queries are
my clicks my impressions my
click-to-rate bike search query
and then the average position so that's
the great thing about that performance
report
is that when i link up google search
console with analytics i'm able to see
that data in
analytics so that's an added bonus so to
speak
now let's talk about some other reasons
why
we're going to use these seo tools
available to us
and so we already listed a number of
different reasons ranging from
site maps to keyword research but
we also want to hone in on you know what
domains
are driving links to our site so
i showed you an example in search
console we also want to
hey maybe identify and disavow poor
backlinks
so search console is a great tool for
that because
if we don't want to be associated with a
particular website we can certainly
disavow
that link we could track a number of
and nofollow links okay we could track
our website's rankings
we can measure click-through rates and
impressions just as we did with search
console
we could track keyword ranking for
desktop mobile cross locations
just as we just did with the search
console performance report
we can identify top performing gaining
and losing keywords
again the performance report so we could
certainly look at the
google search console report but if you
have a platform like moz
you can certainly also look at a lot of
that data available
so for example rankings so if you have a
moz account we can certainly go
into rankings okay and we can see for
the keywords that we've chosen that we
want to optimize for
we could certainly see where they rank
the great thing about moz is
it's a great tool not only for rankings
and on page optimization
but for off page optimization as well
so if i go ahead and take a look at
a domain for example i'm just going to
type in this domain
i'm going to be able to get what they
call a domain authority
so a score out of 1 in 100 i'm able to
see
how authoritative my domain is
and how authoritative a domain is is
based on the quality of links pointing
to it
so moz gives me some good insights
as to how many linking domains how many
inbound links i have
ranking keywords and it goes into detail
as well
so here if i click on the linking
domains i'm going to be actually
able to see the actual domains
pointing to my site as an external link
and not only can i see the domains i can
actually see the domain authority of
those domains
so if there's a domain for example that
doesn't have a good domain authority and
the site appears a bit scammy per se
then we can disavow that so i can
certainly
look at all the domains that are linking
to me and then i can highlight the ones
that have
poor domain authority what mazd even
takes it a step further
they also give me a spam score so moz is
able to measure
how spammy a website is so if i have a
combination of say a low domain
authority
and a high spam score then i probably
want to disavow myself from that site
and so
i can use this report here you can see
here as i keep going down
for example i could see this particular
website has a domain authority
of 26 and it has a spam
score of 16 so not a good combination
this should alert me to the fact that
hey
this particular site because it has so
many
links pointing to me or it has at least
one link pointing to me
that i probably want to disavow myself
because it's probably hurting my own
domain authority
so that's the great thing about this
linking domains report
is i'm able to hone in on not only who's
link
linking to me meaning domain but
how many linking domains does that
domain have what's the spam score of
that domain what's the domain authority
of that domain
and then i can get into a little bit
more detail and actually see
you know all the links pointing to that
domain so it really goes
into detail about backlinks
domain authority spam etc
everything you need to use in order to
measure
off-page seo so that's the great thing
about moz
is they have not only on-page seo tools
but off-page seo tools
and moz is a freemium so to speak so
here you can see if you just go to
moz.com
free dash seo tools you'll be able to
use
some of these tools available to you not
just for seo but also for local
seo as well so here you like some of
these tools you can start your free
30-day trial so i use and lean on moz a
lot
for all that it has to offer from
choosing keywords
to rankings report to checking issues on
my website
to even checking who's linking to me so
this
fits in the mall with everything i need
to do for seo
so in addition to that keyword research
video
you could certainly lean on some other
webinars that we've done in the past on
seo
so we've done a webinar on seo tools and
we've also done
a webinar on seo tips and tricks so if
you want any more information
about the tools we covered or seo in
general
take a look at those two videos and
check them out
and that should kind of complement what
we talked about
with using some of the tools google's
keyword planner
moz and google search console okay let's
switch over
to email marketing tools and so with
email marketing tools
we have a lot available to us
in the form of reporting
in the form of platforms in the form of
you know tools that really help us go
from a to z on our email
choosing you know what email to send out
to creating a list
to measuring how the email campaign went
and so
we could start with mailchimp because
mailchimp's a freemium version
when we say freemium meaning they have a
free trial available
then you're expected to upgrade but you
know mailchimp to me is a tool i use i
like the interface
very easy for beginners so we're going
to take a look at mailchimp but there
are certainly
many others available you know marcato
is a good tool
you know marcato is a good tool because
if you
have a business and you're trying to
funnel people through your pipeline so
to speak
meaning they sign up as a lead and you
want to nurture that lead
from the beginning to the end meaning at
the end they're actually going to turn
around and purchase
well marketo is a good tool for you to
use because you can then set up trip
campaigns or
also known as email campaigns you know
so that you're
talking and communicating with that
particular prospect
through every point in the funnel so
that's the great thing about marketo
it has drip campaigns available along
with some other features
there's a hubspot a very powerful tool
it does a lot
from creating landing pages to a b
testing to
social to you know email so
this is another freemium tool that you
could use
you have another freemium and send in
blue
email platform and then you also have
convertkit another email platform
there's more dimension that we can't
even fit on this screen
now if you have a favorite email
marketing tool that you use
constant contact vertical response there
are plenty out there
emma you know feel free to to note that
in the comment section below this video
i'm curious as to how many people
actually use
you know different tools because there
are so literally
so many email marketing tools out there
why because email marketing
has been around probably the longest
amongst
all the other digital marketing channels
and a lot of people use email on
a daily basis so it's no wonder why
there's just so many tools available
and so with these tools you could
certainly send bulk emails
now in the case of marketo you could
send emails to a segmented audience
and so that's actually what you want to
do as a strategy is always send emails
to
a segmented audience you know you want
to use a tool where you're going to be
able to create campaigns
then send those campaigns to again
segmented contacts
and then be able to design your email
around
that particular audience so you know you
have a good tool when you can do that
when you can really
segment for your audience okay you want
to be able to
use a tool that's going to be able to
segment your users
you know use transactional emails
meaning
hey look if somebody go ahead went ahead
and purchased
can you follow up with an email and
creating workflows just like i mentioned
with marketo you want a workflow
set up where hey if somebody does this
you're sending email b
etc so you want an email marketing tool
that's flexible enough to handle
what your business strategy and goals
are okay so you want to be able to
also use a tool that you know has
various email templates available
okay you don't want to be stuck with
just a vanilla template
again you want to be able to customize
an email for your audience you want to
be able to
manage your list appropriately meaning
if you have 10 000 users or emails in a
list you want to be able to manage
them accordingly you know break them up
or or have sub lists so to speak
and then most importantly you want to
make sure you have a platform that
not only does its tracking on its own
but will give you some detailed insights
meaning
you know what percentage of users opened
your email what percentage of of
recipients
clicked on your email what links do they
click on you know which which emails
bounce so you want some detailed
insights
right in the platform that you're using
it just makes it more
simpler and easier and more effective to
manage you certainly want
to create those smart automated
campaigns
meaning you don't even have to send out
the email and then you want to be able
to have some flexibility to set up email
delivery based on a specific time and
day
so these tools also allow you to you
segment
contacts based on geo location you want
to be able to use a tool that allows for
multi-variant testing
again you want to analyze performance
and optimize campaigns you want to
trigger automatic responses
somebody purchases something are you
using a tool that will automatically
send that email out
so these are all the reasons why you
would use
an email marketing tool so let's dive in
and take a look
at an example and we're going to use
mailchimp as our example today
so let's dive in and take a look at
mailchimp so with mailchimp once you log
in
you know you're going to be able to see
some historical campaigns that you've
sent out
or you're going to be able to create
your own campaign
and so this is kind of under campaigns
you can kind of see an overview of the
ones you've sent out
or if they're in draft mode you'll be
able to see they're in draft mode so you
can go ahead and edit them so
here we have one that was set up on
august 26th and it's still in draft mode
so we can go ahead and edit that
so if we just click edit you know we
have the flexibility to
you know pick and choose who we're
sending this to who it's from what the
subject line is
and then we can certainly design the
email so if we click design
email again this is important because
with email marketing
you want to be able to cater
your email to your intended audience
so if you're selling men's shoes your
audience should be men okay
so you don't want men to receive an
email about women's shoes
it sounds like it's common sense but the
point being you want to be able to use
an email platform that's going to be
able to
allow you to put two and two together
the message and the design with the
intended audience
and so here you can see mailchimp allows
us to do that okay you can see
some of the layouts here okay you also
have themes that you could choose from
okay you could search for different
themes or you can even just code your
own
so you can just paste your code in
or you can import it so mailchimp allows
that flexibility you're not stuck with
one of their templates
and so if we go back to the dashboard
the one thing i like about mailchimp
though
is the reporting okay so yes
it is easy to choose a template and map
that template to your audience
but i really like the reports that they
have to offer
so you know here you can see there's
some lists that we've sent to
and if we choose one of our audience
list
then we can see some really detailed
reporting here
and so here i could see this email that
was sent out in june
i could see it was sent to 95 000 plus
subscribers
okay of the subscribers i saw 2 000 plus
open it
and 157 clicks so i can view
this report in more detail just by
clicking on view report
so again we want an email platform
that's going to be able to give us some
detailed information about
how that email campaign performed and so
i can
get down really to the nitty-gritty i
can actually see
you know on the content what was clicked
and what wasn't clicked
so here i sent two different subject
lines so i'm able to compare the two
against one another
okay so i can really go into detail
about one of them here
so if i click view report i can
specifically see
what the average for this list is so
here i'm able to compare against the
list average
and it's 16 i only had an open rate of
2.5 percent
so the industry average is 18
and so here i'm able to see the list
average for the click rate and the
industry average
for the click rate as well so then i can
see some specifics about it how many
people unsubscribed
then i could see a graph i could see the
top
links that were clicked okay the top
subscribers with the most opens
i can link social to it if i want to and
then i can see geographic
information so the point being is
mailchimp really goes
into some nice detail here about
the email campaigns and how they
performed so the great
thing is too with the mailchimp you
could link it with a google analytics
you can link it with e-commerce okay so
if you have an email
and you're you're selling products and
somebody purchased that product
mailchimp is able to integrate in with
your
shopping commerce platform for example
woocommerce
so if somebody did purchase you can send
out that thank you email
mailchimp even goes a step further and
if somebody did
click on a link go to your shopping cart
add something to the shopping cart
and then abandon the cart you know
mailchimp allows you the opportunity to
retarget them via email so mailchimp is
flexible and that's what you want in a
email marketing platform you want
something that's flexible
that you can cater to your audience you
can manage your audience list
and you can get detailed reporting on
your different campaigns for that
audience
so that's mailchimp in summary and so
most email platforms do a lot of similar
features or have some of the similar
features but that's what you
ideally want to look for in an email
marketing platform
so here's a tool that doesn't get talked
about
enough when it comes to email marketing
and that's google's url builder and the
reason why we're going to talk about
this tool today
is because most people in the us
use google analytics as their web
analytics tool
and the one thing about google analytics
is
it allows you to track different
campaigns so if you're doing
pay-per-click campaigns outside of
google you can certainly track the
performance
right in google analytics and email is
no different
so if you're using google analytics and
you're sending out an email
let's just say on mailchimp or any other
email marketing platform
you want to be able to append your links
with what we call utm tracking so for
example
if i have a url that says visit florida
and i'm going to send out an email i
have
up to five parameters that i can use
okay so here's my email or url that i'm
using
in the email so i have up to five
parameters that i can use
to track this particular email so let's
go through
some of those parameters so the first
one is campaign source
so what's the source of the campaign
well we could certainly
identify mail champion for using
mailchimp as the source
now the the thing about the url builders
you always want to use
lowercase because google analytics is
case sensitive
so as a rule of thumb just stick with a
lowercase
so our source is going to be mailchimp
because that's the platform we're using
if you're using you know constant
contact or vertical response or
you know some of these other one
convertkit then go ahead and put in that
platform as the source now for the
medium
which is the means in which we're
driving traffic to the site
let's go ahead and put in email because
that's what we're using to drive traffic
to this particular page now what's the
campaign name
well we're in summer so we're going to
call this
the summer promo so their summer promo
here is
visit florida beaches okay so we're
going to send this email out to the
masses
and particularly not only the masses but
the masses in the north because we're
going to say hey look
come to florida for the summer come
visit our beaches that's the point of
the campaign
so that's what we're going to use for
the campaign name is whatever the
campaign is
it's a summer promo now notice i got an
asterisk next to these particular
parameters
so google's asking us hey these are
mandatory so go ahead and put something
in there
now for campaign term and campaign
content
we could certainly leave them blank
because they're not mandatory
but since we're talking about email i
would certainly recommend that you use
the campaign content
parameter and why do i say that because
if we're sending an email out
to say you have 10 000
recipients i want to be able to split
out the email
into two segments one segment that's
gonna get subject line one
and one segment that's gonna get subject
line two so
in this case i'm gonna put whatever
subject line one
is in the campaign content field so now
i have four parameters
and once i've entered in my variables in
those parameter fields
i now have a revised or pended url so my
original url
was visit florida.com
us florida dash beaches.html
my original url i've now appended that
with some utm parameters and now
i see my original url appended with the
utm parameters based on those variables
so i can copy it just by clicking the
copy url
i can go to my browser i can paste that
url in there
and i want to check to see if it works
so here i could see
this particular page loaded florida
beaches
with my utm parameters appended to the
url
so that's for the first subject line
that's for the audience that's going to
get the first subject line
i want to do another one for the second
subject line so now i'm going to change
my campaign content parameter to subject
line
underscore 2. i'm going to copy that url
i'm going to check it okay so i can see
that the page loads
with those utm parameters and so now
what am i going to do
i'm going to use the first url and the
second url
in my email okay so any link
that i have in this case i'm using
subject line two
so for the email with the second subject
line
going to that segmented audience this is
the
link i'm going to use in the email so if
you have
one or two or three links in the email
this is the url you're going to use
because when somebody clicks on that
link you're going to be able to see
that that click in google analytics
so if i jump over to google analytics
after i send out my email
i'm going to go to acquisition i'm going
to go to campaigns
i'm going to go to all campaigns now
based on the variables i
put into my parameters
meaning source medium campaign name
content or term that's what i'm going to
look for
in google analytics so we can start with
source and medium
so if i click on source and medium as my
primary dimension
here i can see mailchimp and the actual
date was used as part of the variable
for
for source and then i will can i see the
medium being email
so now i can see for this email that was
sent out in mailchimp in may
i could see how many users how many
sessions and more importantly how many
conversions
so we could certainly hone in on that
particular email if we wanted to
if we choose some of the other
parameters available to us
so here i could see the campaign name
okay so i could see
exactly what campaign what source what
email
drove in traffic and conversions
and if i'm doing subject line testing
i can choose content as my parameter
so here i'm going to change it to
content and now i can see
the subject lines in this case if i go
back to
my source medium i'm going to be able to
see
what subject lines from my emails
generated
the most traffic and not only the most
traffic but also conversions
so that's the whole point behind using
the url builder
again you're taking a url that you're
going to use in email
and then you're going to pan that url
with different parameters
campaign source campaign medium campaign
name
and then optionally campaign content or
campaign term okay once you've entered
variables
into those parameters you're going to
get an appended
url which you can then use in your email
so when the email gets sent you're going
to go back over to google analytics
and you're going to look at the results
of that campaign
of that source of that medium of that
content i.e subject line
and so that's why the url builder is so
important
because mailchimp gives us some good
insight
as to how the email performed in terms
of open and click rates
but what we really want to see is
how that campaign performed once it
drove
traffic to my website so that's the
whole idea behind the url builder
if you're using google analytics you'll
be able to
use the url builder with whatever email
platform you're using
so let's move on to web analytics tools
and this is an important section because
web analytics tools kind of the central
focal point of all
digital marketing and it starts really
with google analytics google analytics
is a
freemium meaning that they have a free
version that you can use
there is also a paid version of google
analytics but given
the advent of google its popularity
especially in the united states
a majority of users are using the free
version
of google analytics so it's a very
popular tool especially for marketers
but there are also other tools available
so it's not just google
so we have adobe analytics which is also
freemium
you have kiss metrics you have spring
metrics
you have youtube analytics which is part
of google
but youtube has its own separate
analytics insights
so a lot of these as you can see are
free to use
they're available no reason why you
should not be using
an analytics tool to measure your
marketing campaigns
or website behavior and why would we
want to use these tools again well
again we want to really measure behavior
we want to measure what's going on with
our website
so we want to be able to identify the
location of where our website visitors
are coming from
and a lot of these analytics tools use
ip address
to identify the location of a website
visitor so
if you're trying to target a specific
country then you want to be able to see
that the visitors to your website are
coming from that specific country or
location
we also want to measure the engagement
of our website behavior so
we get traffic to the website what are
they doing how long are they staying
what pages are they visiting so this is
the overall nature of really why we want
to use web analytics to measure how
successful our website is
at treating our website visitors
with the same courtesy you would if you
had a brick and mortar store
somebody comes into your store you want
them to find what they're looking for
quickly
you want them to be happy with their
experience you certainly want them to
pay
for the products very quickly and easily
and efficiently
and you want them to come back and
that's no different than a website
so we want our website to perform in a
manner that's going to suit our audience
and that's why we want to track
engagement so why else
well we want to really look at who's
coming
are they returning visitors or new
visitors you want to be able to measure
organic traffic whether you like it or
not whether you know it or not but
google
and other search engines are indexing
your pages
and your pages are being found via the
search engines
and so you want to be able to measure
how much traffic you're actually
generating from those search engines
we talked about this with email
marketing utm tracking so
if you set up email campaigns or
non-google campaigns
you want to use utm tracking and google
analytics and other analytics tools but
specifically
google analytics will help you
see the results of your campaigns if
they're tracked
with utm tracking so that's another good
reason why
to use a web analytics tool probably
most importantly amongst
all these bullet points is our goals our
website conversions
we want to be able to see how much
traffic is coming to our website
and not only the engagement of the
traffic but
how much of that traffic is actually
doing what we want them to do
i.e are they converting and we want to
optimize
our sites and channels performance so
the whole idea of collecting
all this information is that you can
turn around
and improve performance so if your
bounce rate is high
well how do you lower bounce rate well
we need to do something about that
and analytics tools will help us
identify what's not working
from our site perspective and from a
channel perspective
and we can take action to improve
performance so that's the whole idea
behind
optimizing our site's performance so
let's jump
into google analytics and let's take a
look
at everything we just talked about in
those bullet points so about
improving website performance measuring
engagement
looking at our goals and conversions
measuring campaigns with utm tracking
all those good things that we can get
in a good analytics tool so adobe
mix panel spring metrics you know they
all work in a similar fashion
in that they're really measuring website
behavior and so if we're in google
analytics really what we're doing
is we're measuring the performance of
our website
broken down into four components
audience
acquisition behavior and conversions
so what do we want to do we want to look
into each one of these sections so let's
start with audience
and so audience and google analytics
tells us
who is coming to our website now they're
not going to specifically tell us
hey rob sanders came to your website but
they are going to say
that somebody from san francisco
california
came to the website and these are the
pages they looked at
and this is the language and they came
from this device
and they're a returning user so they're
painting a picture for you
okay so they're not giving you a list of
names that would not be legal
but they are providing you with a good
picture of who is coming and when i say
picture
we have to paint that picture and so if
we look at say
demographics for example and i go to
demographics
overview here's a picture i'm painting
well i can see that
25 to 34 year olds are the majority
of the age group that is coming to my
website
okay i can see on the gender side of it
i can see
that 63 of my traffic and again this is
year to date that i'm looking at
is coming to my website so two-thirds of
my traffic is female one-third male
and they're between the ages of 25 and
34.
so i'm painting a picture about you know
gender and age coming to my website well
i can also look at geo so where
specifically
might these people be coming from so if
i go to location
under geo i'm going to be able to see a
breakdown of country or i can even hone
it down to city
or specific location and here i could
see
the united states is the primary driver
but not by
much so we have 16 almost 17 percent
from the u.s
and then 16 from argentina 13
from mexico 10 from india so we have a
nice mix
of traffic from different locations in
the world coming to our website so
that's
geo but more importantly let's take a
look at
mobile so if we go to mobile overview
how are people coming to our website are
they
on a desktop or laptop are they using
their mobile device
are they using a tablet and so google
analytics breaks it down
very nice for you and so we could see
percentages
and actual numbers by device category
and so in this case i can see year to
date
i can see 62 percent are coming from
desktop
35 are coming from mobile and so that's
important because
most people start their journey from
mobile
and that is growing and that's going to
continue to grow so you want to keep an
eye on mobile so to me this is one of
the
more important reports under audience
because people who come from mobile have
a
different not only experience because
the website should be responsive
to the mobile device but their mindset
is going to be different they're
actively looking for something they're
probably
going to either then follow up on their
desktop
or follow up in person at your store or
they're probably looking for directions
or they may just call you so the
experience is a lot
different on mobile so we want to hone
in on
the growth of mobile okay so to me this
is one of the more important reports in
google analytics especially under
audience
so let's move on to acquisition
so acquisition reporting tells us how
the traffic was driven to the website
so if audience tells us who is coming
to the website acquisition tells us how
that traffic
got to the website and so really what
you want to do
is get a sense of what channels what
marketing channels
are driving traffic so remember we
talked about organic search well those
search engines are indexing your pages
well
how much of that traffic from the search
engines is actually coming to your site
and i'm a believer in if organic search
is the primary driver of traffic
then you have a pretty healthy website
because that means the search engines
are indexing your pages
people are searching for something
related to your business
you're being found you're getting
clicked and that represents a majority
of the traffic so that's always a good
thing
so here we could see it broken down by
channel if i go to all traffic
channels report i can see in my
dimension
that organic search represents 72
percent of my traffic
when this is year to date then i can see
paid search then i can see direct which
means somebody
went directly to the site i could see
referral
email social then i could see more paid
search broken out
so these are the different marketing
channels now
analytics allows you to look at a
specific source and medium so the source
would be
the actual website or search engine
and the medium would differentiate how
that traffic actually got to the site so
if we're talking about a search engine
did they come to the site via paid
search or do they come to the site via
organic search
and so all we need to do is change our
primary dimension from default channel
grouping to source and medium
and we can see specifically the breakout
of the different sources and mediums
driving traffic to the site
so here i can see google organic at 71
and then google cpc or cost per click at
15
16 of our traffic so then i can look
down i could see
email in here being organic i could see
some referring sites
i could see some social in terms of
mobile facebook
okay so we could see a mix of the
different
sources of mediums driving traffic to
the site okay so you don't always have
to look at channel per se
you can look at it via source and medium
and if you're running google ads
under acquisition analytics has a whole
section of google ads
reporting so if you're running campaigns
on google ads remember we looked at the
keyword planner in google ads so if
you're running
campaigns on google ads you can
certainly see
the performance of those campaigns just
by clicking on
campaigns we can also see
campaigns other campaigns that we're
running so remember that utm tracking
that we set up for email
well we want to be able to
track the performance of email and any
other non-google
campaign with utm tracking so when we do
that we'll be able to go to campaigns
all campaigns and we'll be able to see
the campaign performance if we look at
source and medium
we'll be able to see what campaigns
drove
traffic to the website so here i can see
vertical response
email as a driver of traffic
so that's the campaign reporting and
then also
if you have search consoles so we looked
at search
console earlier we talked about seo
tools
well remember i said you can link up
search console with google analytics
well here's search console and we could
see queries devices
landing pages countries so all the
performance metrics that we could see in
search console
because we have it linked up with
analytics we can see it right here
so this gives us a nice snapshot
of what keywords are driving traffic to
the site
organically i could see the impressions
i could see the clicks
then i could see the clicked array and
then the average position
so in theory the higher something ranks
the more traffic you're going to get
so that's the idea behind it we want to
make sure that
we're ranking for our coveted keywords
and if we are
we want to be able to measure how many
times our listing was seen and how many
times it was clicked so that's the great
thing about
you know google they have a family of
products
and those products tend to talk to one
another in the form of google search
console and google ads
you can connect them directly to google
analytics
so let's move from acquisition to
behavior
so here in behavior we have
a number of different reports so
behavior tells us once the traffic
actually arrived at the website how are
they behaving
and so really what i would do is from
there
go to site content all pages and so this
gives us an
idea of how many pages were actually
viewed
so site content all pages tells us
what page and how many times it was
viewed
during a period of time and again we're
looking at year to date
so i can see engagement related metrics
associated with the page so this
particular page here
on line one i could see how many pages
unique pages which is equal to sessions
so i can have a session come to the
website and look at a page multiple
times in that session
i could see the average time the person
has spent
on a page and i can also see the bounce
rate so
a balance rate indicates that they
arrived on the page
and didn't go any further they left the
website from that page that they arrived
on
and so i can also see percentage of
exits
meaning what page did people exit the
site from
so these are all engagement related
metrics so
here is where i want to react and
optimize my website performance so i if
i see a page not performing well
meaning it has a high bounce rate or
maybe
low time on page then i'm probably going
to optimize it meaning
test it or change it to improve
performance so these are all pages but i
could certainly look at landing pages
okay so landing pages tells us the
behavior of the page when somebody
landed on it
so a landing page means that somebody
came from organic search or paid
search or another channel landed on this
page
so here i could see this particular page
on line one
had 4970 sessions
okay and i can also see the performance
of that pitch so measuring
engagements against pages is definitely
important because
paige isn't performing in terms of
bounce rate or
time on page then we want to be able to
make changes to that page to improve
performance okay there are some other
great reports under behavior
so we want to go to site speed we want
to look at
how fast or how slow our pages load so
this is important from an seo
perspective
because if a page isn't loading very
fast then
chances of it getting ranked in google
are not very good
so google's organic search basically
takes page load time
seriously so if a page doesn't load very
fast then we need to be able to fix it
so
we can go to page timings i can get a
good
sense of the average page load time of a
particular page
and what google does here is under speed
suggestions
they actually will give me some ideas
and speed suggestions
on how to address a page that's loading
very slow
and so when we load up the speed
suggestions report
what google does is say hey we know that
this page is loading very slow
the average page load time is 15 seconds
here's some suggestions we're going to
give you seven suggestions so if you
click on that
what's actually going to happen is
you're going to go to another tool
called page speed insights and page
speed insights is analyzing the page as
you can see here
and when it's done analyzing the page
it's going to give you
some feedback on how to improve page
load performance not only for desktop
but for mobile so here i can see
if i scroll down this is desktop and
these are some of the opportunities that
i can address
when trying to improve the page load
time
of that particular page so here i could
see
there's some server response time issues
image sizes
probably need to be resized i can remove
unused css okay so there are a lot of
different things i can do
to improve the page load time on this
particular page
okay this is for desktop i can also see
mobile
so mobile a lot of the same issues so if
we address
these these opportunities then we could
see a lift and page load time we see
lift and page load time we're going to
probably see a lift in organic rankings
or even user engagement
because if a page takes a long time to
load
a user is probably not going to stay on
that page very long
so to me site speed is an important
report
under behavior now one more report here
that i want to point out under behavior
is events
and to me events are important so if
you're trying to measure
engagement on your website you need to
make sure you have event tracking set up
and
when we talk about event tracking we're
talking about measuring
things that analytics doesn't measure by
default so if you have a button on your
website
if you have a pdf download if you have a
submit button on a form submission
if you have a subscribe button if you
have a video
if you have an external link anything
that is going to trigger
engagement on your website you need to
measure with event tracking
and event tracking is simply set up by
breaking out the event into a category
an action in the label and so here
we could see for our particular website
we have categories already set up for
event tracking
so here for example i can see on line
six video
i could see how many people actually
watched our video
okay so here's the action video start
okay so
over this period of time i could see i
had 49
unique events 50 total so that's how
many people
actually watched the video and you can
always
report to label and that'll tell you
what page
people watched in this case the video so
event tracking is important because we
want to be able to measure
engagement so if you go to events under
behavior
and you don't see any events listed you
probably need to get that set up
and that is set up through google tag
manager so
what you want to do is you want to be
able to set up your events through
google tag manager which is another
google platform
but you certainly want to do that so
that's where you
set up your events when you set up your
events for your website
with a category an action and label
you'll be able to measure
those events in analytics under behavior
under events and the important thing
here is
you'll be able to measure engagement so
i'll be able to see
how many people came to the site and how
many people
clicked on a button downloaded a pdf
uh submitted a form played a video
did whatever we wanted them to do so
events
are important so let's move from
behavior
to conversions and this is important
because
we want to be able to measure
conversions on a website
so analytics has four types of
conversions
so if i go to admin down at the bottom
and then i go to goals i could see that
i have
four different types of goals that i can
use
now right now i have event
related goals set up for the website for
this particular website
so we just talked about event tracking
so if you're
measuring a button click on your website
you can certainly turn that into a goal
and so all you need to do is tell
analytics hey
this is the particular category this is
the particular action
so for example if i click on this
particular goal
and take a look at it i can see that we
have a category
set up that anything that resembles
donate now
okay or donate go ahead and fire this
event as a conversion okay so event is
one type of goal another type of goal is
destination
so somebody goes to a specific page like
a confirmation page
we can turn that into a goal so here i
can see if somebody
goes to donation dash confirmation then
analytics is going to fire that goal as
a conversion
and we're going to see a conversion
against a different metric or different
dimension like
channel or audience okay so destination
is the second
type of goal the third type of goal is
duration
so how long did somebody stay on my
website so in this example if they
stayed
at least one minute and 30 seconds or
more
then analytics is going to count that as
a goal conversion
okay so duration is the third type and
then the fourth type
is pages per session okay so if i look
at this example
here if a user came to my website
and looked at more than three pages in
that particular session
then analytics is going to fire a goal
conversion
so four types of goals you don't have to
set up all
four different types my recommendation
is at least have
one goal set up if you're not sure what
goal to set up
then at least set up a duration or pages
per session okay so at least you can
measure
how long somebody stays on your website
or how many pages they went to
okay so when you actually do have these
goals set up you can go back
into conversions we can go back into
goals we can go back into overview
and we can measure our goal completions
over this period of time so here i could
see 313 goal completions total
with a goal conversion rate of 1.88
and then i could see it broken down by
gold type
so remember the only goals i have
available and set up
are event related goals so 69 newsletter
sign
ups 156 donate click buttons
i have 32 contact form submissions
37 email click completions and then 11
phone number click completions so i can
measure
engagement as a goal and so goals
generally are important to the business
so you want to make sure that if you
have a goal for your website
then you want to be able to set that up
as a goal
in google analytics so that way when
you're looking at example
channels if i go back to my channels
report i can then
measure channel by goal conversion
so these are all goals but if i want to
look at for example
how many people from organic search
clicked on the donate
now button i could see that i could see
year to date
10 887 users which meant
11 000 sessions 76 clicked on that
donate now button
and that comes out to 0.65
conversion rate okay so that's important
so you want to be
able to measure any dimension whether
that be
channel source medium keyword
campaign mobile device could be
demographic
gender or age you want to be able to
measure any dimension
against the goals you have set up so you
can measure performance
and that also includes pages or landing
pages as well
so that's a quick overview of what you
can expect to see
in google analytics again audience
acquisition behavior and conversions
so a lot of data in google analytics but
you want to be able to take advantage of
the data
in order to improve website performance
now let's jump over to youtube analytics
because
if you have videos on youtube if you
have a channel set up
some playlists you'll be able to get
some really
good insights as to how your video is
performing
and so here i could see i'm in youtube
all i did was i went to my account
then i went to the beta the studio
version
of youtube and then from there i went to
analytics
so my account youtube studio analytics
and analytics here is going to give me
all sorts of information
about my videos okay so here i could see
over the last
28 days my videos produced over 8
600 views my watch time in minutes
totaled over 17
000 and i've netted 48 subscribers
and this is an overall okay so i can
actually see
when i publish videos and i can see the
date they were published
and here i'm looking at you know total
views
over this particular date range i can
also see
specifics on a particular video so i
could see the top video in terms of
minutes
here i could see this particular video
had 602 minutes
over the last 28 days so here i could
see views
on a particular video so this is just an
overview
i could certainly look at some other
information if i click on reach viewers
i could see
the total impression so how many times
my video
was viewed or how many people looked at
it okay and then the click-through rate
so here i could see the different
traffic sources
so 29 came externally okay here i could
see 25
came within youtube itself i could see
how many times a video was viewed and
played via playlist
via suggested videos so i could see
different ways in which
the traffic found my video and actually
watched it
here i could see externally how people
were able to find my videos
and i could see 46 percent found it via
google search
see some lots of information here about
sources of traffic how the traffic got
to these videos
so i could see then once the traffic
found my videos
how many times they actually saw it and
viewed it
and then watched it so that's how many
times
i was able to reach viewers via
different sources
and then their reaction to that how many
times i saw it and watched it
here i can click on interest viewers so
again i could see the top videos in
terms of
watch time i could see the top playlist
so here i could see my partner's
playlist was the top playlist
so i can see some interest here in terms
of average
view duration and then here we have
build an audience
so we can look at specific audiences if
we have them built in youtube
to see how many people actually watch my
videos so
here i can see 88 of the people who
watched my videos over the last 28 days
were not even subscribed so that tells
me a lot of people
are finding my videos spending some time
watching them
they're not subscribed so we're trying
to get them to subscribe to our channel
so they can watch
more so a lot of information here
in youtube itself about how our videos
performed again this is good insight
because ideally what you want to do
is you really want to take a look at a
specific video
see how it's performing so if i just
click on one particular video
i can actually see the audience
retention
over the course of the video itself i
could see
the ways in which people found the video
okay again externally or via youtube
search i could see how many people liked
it or disliked it
i could see all sorts of information on
a particular video
itself or an overview of my channel
so that's all available to you in
youtube analytics
under youtube studio so take advantage
of that so if you're publishing videos
on a regular basis you want to
hone in on how your videos are
performing
so if you have any additional questions
about youtube analytics or
youtube in general take a look at our
video that we created earlier
this year about how to create a youtube
channel we go into
some in-depth insights into youtube
itself
especially youtube analytics so take a
look at that video
and if you have any other insights about
youtube analytics or analytics in
general
go ahead and put a comment below this
video so let's turn our attention
to competitor spine tools very important
to keep tabs on what the competition is
doing and there are a lot of tools out
there
so when it comes to social we can use a
freemium tool like sprout social
to listen in on our competitors we can
use another freemium tool
social blade there's a popular tool out
there called spyfu
that's freemium as well moz we looked at
moz
earlier for keyword and organic mozz is
a great tool
for also leveraging our competitors in
terms of backlinks
and buzzsumo so that's another freemium
tool
get there lots of tools out there these
are just
examples of some of the tools that we
use here at simply learn i use
personally and professionally
to get a sense of what our competition
is doing so why would we want to use
a competitor spine tool well it may
sound like a very straightforward
question
but there are lots of reasons why and so
let's look at some of these reasons and
the first reasons we really want to
identify
you know our competitors backlinks and
monitor changes in their ranking
so the reason why we have this is the
top bullet point is because
seo organic search is a long term
strategy
on page off page website very technical
and creative there's a lot going on with
seo
a lot going on and sometimes it takes a
long time to rank for something
and a lot of seo does depend on
relevancy relevancy being
how many quality backlinks are linked to
you so it's always good to leverage what
your competitors are doing so you can
see how you
stack up and so that's why this is up
there as number one we want to be able
to
really take a look at what our
competitors are doing
another example would be hey how much
traffic a competitors gaining on
certain keywords this could go either
way for paid search
organic search what are competitors
bidding on are they really
getting traffic from those keywords so
there are tools out there
that help us leverage what our
competition is doing okay we can also
identify
our competitors top performing content
for relevant topics
okay we can determine what our
competitors website referral traffic is
okay we can pull our competitors data
and compare it with their own campaigns
so lots of tools out there to help you
do this
and we may want to track the total
amount of clicks a competitor receives
and how much they pay for each keyword
so
let's go ahead and take a look at a few
examples
how we can leverage all these bullet
points that we just discussed
and so we're going to start out with
sprout social
and sprout social is a tool i use it's a
social media platform there's a lot of
things you can do
with sprout social definitely generate
reports for your social media platforms
you could set up posts that get
published at a certain
time and day but there's also one
particular tool in here called listening
and so what we could do is we just put
in for example
rv rentals in twitter so what we're
doing is we're actually
listening to see who else is tweeting
about
rv rentals so we could do this for
twitter we could do it
facebook some other social media
platforms the whole idea here
on sprout social is to get a sense of
what our competitors are doing
so we could have easily put in a brand
name we're just going general here
because we want to rank for the keyword
rv rentals
and so here we could take a look at you
know what some of these
particular brands are doing like go rv
rentals cruise america rv
we could see just scroll down and we can
get a sense of
in particular what people are tweeting
about what other companies are tweeting
when it comes to this particular keyword
rv rentals
now if i want to hone in on a particular
competitor i could just
really refine my search for that
competitor's brand names or rv
share so here i can take a look at
you know what they're doing when they're
posting to or tweeting
how long ago the time of day get an idea
of what
they're actually saying what campaigns
they're promoting
okay i can get a sense of everything
about this tweet
and so here i can scroll down and i can
see what's been shared by other people
for this particular brand
and i can see a lot of people are as an
example
retweeting this particular giveaway and
so
to me it just gives me a sense in this
particular example on twitter
as to what are competitors doing okay
let's turn our attention to
seo so remember that first bullet point
we want to get a sense of what our
competitors are doing when it comes to
backlinks
and so moz has a great tool called link
explorer
and link explorer there allows us to
actually compare link profiles so for my
domain i can go ahead
and put my competitors domains in there
and
definitely get a sense of you know
how many links my competitors have
external intel
internal i can get a sense of the domain
authority
i can get a sense of page authority
linking domains
so i can really do a comparison
across my domain and my competitors
domains to get a snapshot of
how i compare against my competitors so
this gives me an overview of everything
i need to know organically now moz also
has a
another great tool under link explorer
called link intersect
and i like link intersect i use it a lot
because
if our competitors really have a number
of external links and domains pointing
to their site
and they have a better domain authority
and page authority
then you know i want to be able to you
know
see what they're doing where they're
linking who's linking to them
i want to get be able to get a snapshot
of why is their domain
so much better than ours in terms of
authority and so the link
intersect actually allows me to do that
so i can go ahead and put my competitors
domains in there
and then i can find opportunities and so
you just click on opportunities and you
can see
where my site intersects with their site
and if it doesn't actually intersect
then i
have an opportunity to actually
try and get a link on that particular
site so that's what the link intersect
report does
it allows me to see where my links
intersect with my competitors
and if it doesn't intersect then i have
an opportunity to generate a backlink so
that's ideally what the link intersect
tool is
in moz it allows me to really get a
sense of
you know where i'm linking and where my
competitors are linking
now what we can also do is also take
advantage of another
report under moz's link explorer and the
discovered and lost report
so we could put in our domain or we
could put even our competitors domain in
there
and we can get a sense of what domains
were found and linked to them
so really within mods we can get a good
snapshot
of what websites are linking to our
competitors
we get a good snapshot of the overall
links to our competitor sites
and specifically with sites so the whole
idea is
if it's good for our competitors meaning
they're linking from a site that has
good domain authority and low spam score
then it's probably a site i want to be
able to tackle as well okay so
you have discovered and lost okay you
have
comparing link profiles and you have
link intersect
so those are three good reports you can
leverage
right in moz's link explorer tool
now there's one more report we can
leverage in moz
and that's the inbound links report and
so we can go
ahead and type in our competitors domain
here and again we can get a snapshot of
what their domain authority is
page authority for the home page but
really this is what we're after
linking domains so this particular
domain has over 9 000
linking domains so what we can do is
actually
go through and see based on domain
authority
i could sort by domain authority where
these pages are being linked from and so
here i can see reddit
reddit reddit so a lot of reddit here
which is a good
site for backlinking new york times so
you know there's a lot of different uh
sites here washington post
so i can get a good snapshot of my
competitor by seeing
every link that's pointing to them now
of course i don't want to go through
9000 links i can really just hone in on
a specific
link source or link type or link state
so i can really filter it if i wanted to
i can export the report
and do some further analysis but really
the whole idea here as i could see
what url is linking to this particular
competitor
site what the anchor text is what the
page and domain authority is
so this gives me a really really good
insight on
all the backlinking that my competitor
has and again
if i'm trying to catch my competitor
it's probably not a bad idea
to look at what they're doing and even
copy what they're doing in terms of
backlinking
so if we're not on reddit then we
probably need to be on reddit because if
that's where our competitor is
and they're getting good link juice from
reddit which has a domain authority of
90
then hey if it's good for the goose it's
good for the gander so they say
so inbound links is it just another good
report you can leverage
in moz under the link explorer reporting
tool
now if i want to get a good snapshot as
to what my competitors doing
on search exactly well look no further
than spyfu so spyfu
is a another tool that you can leverage
from a ppc
seo perspective you know from an seo
perspective you got some
back linking data as well just like you
did in moz
from a ppc perspective you can get some
good keyword insights
and so here i just went ahead and typed
in the domain
and what this is going to do is just
give me an overall snapshot
for my competitors domain so here i
could see
you know how many organic keywords
they're found for the
estimated monthly seo clicks they're
getting based on the volume of those
keywords okay i can see here the
keywords their top competitors
also rank for the rank history 12 years
so
this particular domain has been around a
long time okay
so that's on the organic side you can
flip over to the paid side
and i could see that they are doing paid
search i could see
5 000 plus keywords they're bidding on
okay based on that what they're actually
paying
and then i could see you know some of
the other competitors listed here from a
paid perspective
and an organic perspective i could see
the shared keyword
overlap okay now again you can pay for
this because it's freemium
and get some really good insights as to
how your domain
compares to your competitors so i'm
using the free version
and here the free version spyfu is just
giving me some overall data on the
specific domain i entered in and so
i entered in my competitors you can
certainly enter in your own domain to
get a sense
of organic keywords and paid keywords so
you can see
top keywords top paid keywords
okay this is google ads okay so this is
what recommendations as to what to
purchase okay here you could see some
even some
at google ads history i could see
exactly
what ad copy my competitor actually
wrote and for what keyword
and then i can see some organic ranking
history here as i keep scrolling down
this overview report so i can see for rv
rent
where they rank and then i can see
inbound links just like i did in moz
spyfus providing me with some insight as
to
hey what links are pointing to them and
what the domain strength is and
how many clicks they expect to receive
so this is all
free data take it or leave it but it's
all free data
available to you under spyfu so spyfu
gives you
kind of an overview for free some really
in-depth analysis if you actually pay
for it
and it just really hones in on what your
competitors are bidding for
paid wise and what they're ranking for
organic-wise
and so spy food is a really good tool to
leverage if you just want to get a
snapshot of
how your competitor overlaps with you so
let's turn our attention to google
analytics because
in google analytics under audience i can
go to
benchmarking and basically the
benchmarking reports
allows me to see what the industry as a
whole is doing compared to my own
website
now the caveat here on this particular
report is that
it's all anonymous data so i can't
exactly
see what competitor is doing what
in this report but if i hone in on my
industry in this case
autos and vehicles and i hone in on a
specific country
or adjust the size of the daily sessions
that i get
then i could see hey analytics in this
case
in this example sharing 863
web properties okay so they're sharing
the data for over
8 000 web properties and i can compare
those web properties against my own so
if we're all in the same industry
it gives me a sense here as to how i
stack
up against the industry as a whole in
this case
as it pertains the channels so you can
see here
red not good green is good so in the
industry we're not
doing as good as others in the same
industry who are receiving
the same amount of sessions now we could
certainly adjust
and we can adjust our locale and if we
do that
google's going to be able to adjust how
many web properties are
actually contributing to the report and
so
when analytics makes that adjustment
we're going to be able to see in this
case
just new zealand so we're going to
adjust for new zealand
and we're going to go with 4999
and so we could see there are about you
know 300
something web properties contributing 47
web properties now contributing to
this report so we're focused on the new
zealand region
and this is the amount of traffic we get
we're now comparing us against 47 other
anonymous web properties so now if i go
back to the report
after i've honed in i'm looking at
channels and i can see
how many sessions we're getting by
channels and how i compare
against the competition i can also
measure up against
percentage of new sessions new users
pages per session
average session duration bounce rate but
that's just channels i can also do
location
and devices so the whole idea behind
this report
is yes you're not honing in on a
particular competitor
but you're honing in on your industry so
you're getting a good idea
as to how you compare against your
industry just by making some adjustments
in the benchmarking report you obviously
want to make sure
you're looking at the same industry
adjust for your country or region
adjust for the site size meaning how
many
sessions you actually get on a daily
basis and then analytics will do the
rest they'll compare
you against those in your industry and
so i find this to be a good tool
because it allows me to stack up our
site against those in the industry
and obviously if we're not driving as
many sessions especially say
from organic then we have our work cut
out for us okay so that's the whole idea
behind
the benchmark report now if you want to
get some good
insight as to what the competitors are
doing and you don't want to use a tool
well look no further you can always go
to google.com
okay so this is how we used to do it
back in the day before all these tools
became available you just typed in a
keyword and we're going to type in rv
rentals and now
we're going to be able to see who's
bidding on that keyword
so we could see we have a number of
different
uh companies bidding on the keyword
we're interested in okay here i can see
some featured snippets
okay and then i could see some organic
search results okay if i scroll down
i'll be able to see some other companies
bidding on that same keyword meaning
they're paying for rv rental so if i
clicked on somebody's link here they're
actually going to pay
google for the click and so this just
gives me a good sense
of you know how many people are actually
trying to rank for this keyword or
trying to be found for this keyword
so that's all i did i just did a search
now from an organic perspective if you
really want to hone in on your
competition
you can always do the syntax all in
title colon and then hit enter so now
i could see i have 163 000 results and
what does that tell me
that tells me that i have 163 000
websites with rv rentals in the title
tag
so if you're trying to optimize for the
keyword rv rentals as an example
then you know that you have 163
000 different listings ahead of you
that you need to jump over in order to
rank for the keyword rv rentals
so using the all in title syntax and the
keyword right after that
actually just gives you a more accurate
picture of
how many sites are actually ahead of you
for a particular keyword so that's the
whole idea so if i get rid of the syntax
and you can see for rv rentals i have
132
million but that's not really accurate
because not all these listings have the
keyword
rv rentals in the title tag and title
tag if you're working on organic search
is one of the key important factors for
ranking so you need to have that keyword
in the title tag
so that's the whole idea behind using
the all in title syntax
it gives us a good idea as to what our
competition is doing and how many sites
we have to jump over
to get to number one on google now if
you're running
google ads just as we did with rv
rentals
we went up there and we saw we typed
that in as a query and we saw how many
advertisers there were for rv rentals
now if we are running our own campaigns
google ads actually has a good report
that i really like
it's called auction insights and so you
can get to auction insights just by
clicking on campaigns
and then from campaigns click on auction
insights and when auction insights
allows us to see
is what competitors or domains are
bidding on the same keywords we are
and so what google does here is it
allows us to
actually see where we stack up against
our competition
for all the keywords we're bidding on
and so here i'm looking at year to date
and here we could see us and i can see
our competitors
okay so i could see impression share so
for if we're talking about one
word every keyword has a hundred percent
impression share
how much of that impression share are
you getting and when we say impression
share meaning
eyeballs when we talk about eyeballs are
we getting a majority of the eyeballs
or our competitors get a majority of the
eyeballs so we can see
our average position i can see how often
i overlap with my competitors
okay i could see how often i'm above a
particular competitor
i could see what percentage i'm at the
top of the page versus my competitors
the absolute top of page rate and then i
can see how often i
out rank my competitors and vice versa
how often my competitors outrank me
so i could see all this good insight as
to
what competitors are bidding on the same
keywords i am
okay so this is if you're running google
ads okay so if you're running google ads
okay
you can just click on the auction
insights report you can find that the
top navigation
just by clicking on campaigns and by
doing so
you'll be able to gain some insights as
to
where you stack up from a paid search
perspective
against your competitors so let's turn
our attention
to paid marketing tools
so if you're doing some advertising on
google
bing linkedin you probably want to work
within those platforms as the tool of
choice
so you know if you're doing paid search
on say google search dot com or
display you could be doing display
advertising on
you know a network like adroll or google
or you could be doing social media paid
ads say on
facebook so whatever it is you're doing
you probably want to work
within that platform itself to get the
ideal data that you need
okay so here are some of the tools some
of the places you can go
of course if you work in google ads you
also have google ads editor
that you can leverage okay and i'll show
you that in a couple minutes
you have google ads keyword planner of
course both of these are
paid if you're running campaigns okay so
bing if you're running campaigns on bing
okay you get all this good
data that you can digest through some
reporting
okay you also have some third-party
tools out there that you also have to
pay for in word stream okay so
wordstream is a third-party tool that
you can leverage
bing and google are actual advertising
networks so you would advertise on the
platform itself
and get all the data you need right in
the platform
and leverage a lot of the tools that
they have available in the platform
as i mentioned you could also use google
ads editor
uh so bing also has their own editor as
well
so and as well as facebook so you can
use
an editor type version and i'll show you
that here in a couple minutes but
let's talk about why we want to use the
tools in the platform itself well
we want to be able to monitor how our ad
is performing
so which ad receives the most traffic as
an example
we want to identify keywords that are
performing for us
okay so our keywords converting not
converting now they cost us a lot of
money
and not netting a high enough return for
us so we want to keep an
eye on that because we want to monitor
our cost okay across different locations
and devices
not only cost but we want to also
monitor
how our ads are performing across
different locations of devices
keywords across different locations and
devices
so we want to be able to measure by
device
okay so we also want to analyze
competitors data
and as we showed you in the competitors
section google as an example
has auction insights reporting analytics
has benchmarking so google itself
does provide some information in the
case of auction insights
as to how uh your competitors are
performing against you
on google search so that's on the paid
search side then you have display
okay so display advertisements okay
you're across a different network
so there are different types of networks
out there for example
admiral okay you have curtillo celtra is
another paid
version of or paid tool you can use in
wide orbit so these are some of the
paid marketing tools you can leverage of
course
i like to stay if i'm advertising on
google i like to stay
on google ads and measure my display
performance that way
but if you're on adroll for example then
you want to leverage
adroll's reporting platform and some of
the tools they have to offer so
if we look at display why do we want to
leverage some of these tools
well just like search for example where
we want to look at keyword and ad
performance
same kind of concept here we want to be
able to monitor
whether we have the right keywords and
write customer engagement
so when it comes to display we want to
be able to
make sure we're choosing the right
audience of course that means
looking at not only audience insights
but our target
insights as well are we reaching the
right audience when it comes to display
and google has a good breakdown that i'm
going to be able to show you here in a
couple of minutes
okay so we want to improve our campaigns
by monitoring
our competitors display ads as well so
there are tools available that will help
you do that
and that's on the display side if we
look at social okay
why what tools can we use on social well
you got
facebook ads manager okay you got ad
espresso
choir tweepy you got all these cool paid
search tools again i usually stick with
where i'm advertising so if i'm
advertising on linkedin or twitter i'm
going to leverage that platform but just
know that there are
other tools available for you so with
social
like display it's all about targeting
our audience so
for these some of the tools like on
facebook we can review and relaunch
our ad campaigns based on target
audience we can measure conversions and
gain
insights in this example about facebook
users
how are our users interacting with
our ads and then we want to target
people based on their activities such as
purchase intent device usage travel
preferences etc so social allows us to
do that
and then with facebook as an example we
can monitor
any a b test we run for example if we're
running
call to action test we can measure the
results that write in facebook and i'm
going to show you an example of that
here shortly
so let's jump right into google ads
and look at some tools available to us
from the search side of the house so for
running search campaigns
right in google ads we could see
campaign data we could see
keyword data we could see ad data so for
example if i want to see what ads are
performing
i'm just going to click on my ads and
extensions okay
and here are my ads and now i can see
what ads are performing in terms of
clicks
click-through rates etc and so that way
i can go ahead and pause ads
activate ads so that's right here in
the google ads platform itself
now if i want to look at specific
keywords i can do that
so i could see what keywords are driving
traffic and clicks
here i could just sort by clicks and now
i can see
not only what keywords are driving
clicks i could see
what the click-through rate is i could
see the impressions how many people
actually viewed my ad
after click typing in a keyword query
that i'm bidding on
i could see how much i've paid by
keyword and more importantly i want to
be able to see
conversions or conversion rate and then
with google ads you have quality scores
so we want to be able to measure
quality score so this is a google
ads keyword reporting and so the great
thing about
the keyword reporting is that there's
some
other features available to me here so
here i can add negative keywords okay
just by clicking on negative keywords i
can also see
a search terms report and so when it
comes to search terms i can actually see
what specific keywords people typed in
and
based on the keyword that somebody typed
in as a query i can
see what match type triggered that
particular ad and so if i see a keyword
query
that i don't particularly care to be
shown for
or i want my ad shown for then i can go
ahead and just select it
and i can add it as a negative keyword
okay so that tool is available to you
right in google ads
okay and then you have the auction
insight so we've reviewed the auction
insights when we're looking at
competitive
analysis and so here if we look at the
auction insights
we'll be able to adjust our date range
and we'll be able to see
basically you know who else is bidding
on the keywords
and what the impression share is what
their average position is
what the overlap rate is position above
right
top of page absolute top of page right
now ranking chair so
once we have google has data then
they'll be able to share that
information with you
okay so that's just keywords but there's
a cool tool that i really like
and i leverage it for seo and
pay-per-click and that's google's
keyword planner so if you click on tools
and then you click on keyword planner
we'll be able to
leverage the keyword planner and the
whole idea behind the keyword planner
is do we want to discover new keywords
or for the keywords we have selected we
can get
volume and forecast on that so here
let's type in a keyword
mail delivery and if i click get started
okay
so google's going to give me some other
keyword ideas
and they're going to give me what the
average monthly searches are for that
keyword
they're going to let me know the
competition they're going to give me a
range
in terms of how much i can expect to pay
for that keyword
so if i happen to click on that keyword
i can add it to a plan
and then once i've added to a plan then
i can go ahead
and look at that plan and
measure what kind of volume i'm going to
get and how much i can expect to pay
so now once i've added my keyword to
that plan
i can go ahead and see
how many clicks and impressions and
costs and click the rate and average
cost per click i can expect to spend
so and this is based on
a maximum cpc of two dollars so i can go
ahead and adjust my plan accordingly
if i want to in order to see basically
how much i can expect to spend so that's
the whole idea behind the keyword
planner
in terms of choosing new keywords and
once you choose keywords you're
interested in bidding on you can
actually do a forecast to see exactly
how much you can expect to spend
how many clicks how many impressions you
can expect to get
and if you have conversions set up how
many conversions you can expect to
receive so that's all part of google's
keyword plan that's viewing forecast
as well as choosing keywords so there
are so
many different tools and features within
google ads
we need a whole whole segment just on
this
so really i'm just going to highlight
some of the more important
tools and features so i mentioned the
keyword planner i mentioned the
campaigns
keywords and ads reports another thing i
would look at in google ads again we
mentioned this is one of
our key defining why would we use it
bullet point and that's because of
devices so we mentioned devices why
would we use
google ads reporting tool because we
want to look at devices
and we want to be able to see what
devices are driving traffic
from what campaign and then the cool
thing about
google ads is right in google ads
platform you can go ahead and do a bid
adjustment so
if i increase my bid adjustment for
example on mobile phones
then my particular ad in this particular
campaign
is going to show more than on computer
so i can always decrease it
for example do a bid adjustment on
computer
and that means i'm going to show my ads
less so
i can go ahead and do bit adjustments
based on device
that's the cool thing of working right
in google ads platform is you can make
adjustments
right here in the platform based on
devices well you also have locations too
so we mentioned that as one of the
reasons why we want to use some of these
tools
and if i see a particular location i'm
not
interested in advertising well i can
always select it
and i can always just pause it or remove
it so
or i can change the bid adjustment on a
location as well
so i can make a lot of different changes
right
in the google ads platform for those
seasoned
in search advertising paid search
advertising
especially on google ads you can always
use google ads editor
all you need to do is just do a search
for google ads editor you can
download it so basically what google ads
editor is it's a
it's a tool it's the software that you
work
your ca with your campaigns on locally
so you're making changes to your
campaigns
on your computer and basically when
you're done making changes
you can always upload them to
google ads to the account on google ads
in the cloud so to speak
so that's the whole idea behind google
ads editor
it's a great tool for you to use if you
want to make household changes
really quick for example i'm looking at
an account
with a bunch of campaigns
so now if i click on one of those
campaigns i could see the ad groups here
okay so for example i just wanted to
turn off all these ad groups i can just
highlight them all
and just click status enable to pause
and i can revert back if i want to
okay so you can make household changes
so here i could see at the campaign the
ad group level if i choose an ad
group then i can see some keywords and
again i can make changes
at nauseum here i can copy i can paste
i can delete okay so i can make a lot of
changes
really quick right in google ads editor
and that's the whole point of editor
is to go ahead and work locally while
somebody else is working locally
on the same account you could both be
working simultaneously
and being more efficient on getting
things done
in the campaign now if you are working
with somebody else on the campaign
you want to make sure that you get
recent changes so
if i say get recent changes to all
campaigns
what google editor is going to do is
contact google ads in the cloud
and download all those changes so here i
can see the changes being download
in editor from google ads and when it's
done
it's going to highlight all the changes
that have been made
and so once i'm done reviewing those
changes i can go ahead and click done
and now i know i have the recent latest
changes in editor
so now i can go ahead and continue to
make some changes and when i'm done
making changes i can go ahead and post
them
so that's the beauty of google ads
editor bing has a version
facebook has a version it allows you to
again go at the keyword level
the ad group level okay you can look at
ads itself
and make changes to the ads okay you
could do a lot of different things write
an editor in fact you could do pretty
much
most of what you could do in google ads
you can do in google ads editor
and so that's google ads editor to me i
would recommend it if you're experienced
with google ads again it's software you
have to download it
you're going to use it on your computer
as software
but when you make changes all you need
to do is post those changes
or get recent changes that have been
made on google ads
and so that's google editor ads editor
in summary now let's go back into google
ads
and talk about display advertising
because display is a different network
but the platform's still the same and
some of the
same tools are available from the search
network
as well as for the display network right
in google ads so
if i want to take a look at a campaign
an ad group
on the display network i could just
click on that ad group
and i can look at the ads that are
running for
that particular ad group on the display
network so here
the difference being on the display
network is you can use
image ads on the search network you can
only use text ads
so here i can look at image ads and i
can see
how they're performing in fact you could
even go a step
further and use responsive display ads
so google has responsive display ads
meaning
it's going to respond to what's
performing best
okay and so now i can see clicks
impressions click-through rate etc
right on on my ads and extensions
report in google ads platform now this
happens to be retargeting campaign
so if we click on audiences we'll be
able to see what
audiences we're targeting here okay so
when this report loads when you run
retargeting campaigns
you're targeting a specific audience and
so
we want to be able to see okay of the
audiences we have set up
what audience is performing best okay so
here i can see a breakout
by audience again i could see the same
metrics i could see
on the search side i could see clicks
impressions click to rate more
importantly
i want to be able to measure conversions
okay so that's the whole idea when
you're in these platforms and you're
paying
for ads is you want to be able to
measure against conversions
and you can also measure against cost
per conversion conversion rate
okay so those are some key metrics to
measure up against whether it's
audience keyword ad whatever the
dimension is
so here on the display network we can
get a sense of
demographics okay so unlike the search
network the display network allows us to
see
demographic data and so now i could see
an
age breakout or an age range breakout
that google provides us and i can see
again based on the age
range breakout which age range has the
most clicks impressions
etc including conversions so
you also have the opportunity on the
display network to add keywords
you have the opportunity topics and you
have the opportunity
to see placements or run placements so
here if i click on where ads have shown
i can actually see
where my ads have shown up for this
display campaign
and google ads allows you the ability to
go ahead
and you can exclude it from the ad group
exclude a specific placement from a
campaign so you could take action
on a specific placement and i could see
the type of placement whether it's a
mobile app whether it's a site
i can go ahead and see exactly where
that placement was
so that's the placements report you have
demographics you have audiences you have
keywords you have all these
different reports available to you on
the google ads
platform so before we jump over to
social media paid search advertising i
just want to remind you we do
have you know a nice tutorial on google
ads
okay so take a look at the google ads
tutorial we have set up
on youtube okay if you search for google
ads tutorial 2019
this is a good uh tutorial on everything
related to google ads so check out this
video
because in today's webinar we're just
mentioning tools across the board
and if you are advertising on google
ads as most people do then you can see
just how powerful it is and all the
different features that are available
so take a look at the video it's a nice
complementary video to
this one this digital marketing tools
and this will give you a nice
and deeper insight into everything
that's available on google ads
and if you have any tools or features
on google ads whether it's the search
network or whether that's the display
network
then feel free to comment below this
video
happy to hear your comments about what
tools and
reports and features you specifically
use
in google ads so let's move into
facebook ads manager and show you how
the platform looks when you're running
ads on facebook so we can look at all
the different tools and reports
available here
so here we can see if we're in the
facebook ads manager
we could see our campaigns we can see
our ad sets
and we can see our ads so just like on
google ads
you have less side navigation so we can
drill down so if we want to see ad
sets for example we could just click on
ad sets
that are showing up in this particular
account and here we can see we have two
ad sets that are live
so if i click on one of these ad sets
i'll be able to see
an actual ad that's running here and so
for the actual ad that's running i can
then see
the results of that ad and how it's
performing for example
you know how many clicks it's received
what the reach is
what the impressions are so impressions
similar to google ads
how many people are actually looking at
the ad and i can see the cost per click
here at one dollar
as an example and so now i can go in
and i can go ahead and look at the ad
performance
and go ahead and change out that ad if
it's not performing
to my expectation so if i click
on more tools and then creatives i can
just simply click on creators and then i
can actually see
the create is i actually have running
for that campaign i selected
so now i can see all the creatives that
are running and i can see the results of
those creatives so
facebook ads manager also has uh read
different reporting so if i click on the
reports pull down menu
you can see here i could see some
standard reports by add
ad set age and gender and then i can see
all reports here
listed out by placement by placement and
device
time of day country etc so if we just
look at age and gender we'll be able to
get a breakout
age and gender here so you can see by
campaign
i'm looking at all campaigns here and
i'm looking at just
age and gender i can certainly deselect
one of these
and i can look at a specific time range
so now i could see
who's looking at my ad specifically so
here i could see
35 to 44 female i could see the reach
impressions and how often they're
actually seeing my ad
now this is key for facebook because if
somebody's seen your ad
a lot they're probably going to tune out
to it so that's what makes the frequency
metric so important on facebook because
then we can go ahead
and you know turn off that particular
age
and gender if we needed to and we could
see
how much we spent so this just gives you
some idea of the type of reporting
that's available
in facebook ads manager now the great
thing about
facebook uh reporting in ads manager
is you know i can group or ungroup uh
my dimensions if i needed to i could
change the view and arrange columns i
can get rid of columns
just as you would in google ads
reporting very similar stature here
so i have a lot of flexibility here on
how i review the reports
you know you got different metrics that
you could pick and choose as well
okay and you got lots of different
flexibility when you're looking at the
reports
on how your campaigns are performing now
here i can pick and choose
i can choose campaign ad set ads
objective again i can choose different
demographics
so i have a lot of options available to
me in terms of how
i want to you know view the performance
of my campaign view the performance of
my ad set or my ad
now remember if you're in facebook you
can always go in and edit the campaign
you can edit the ad set
remember in the ad set that's where a
lot of
your decisions are going to be made
including
how you want to drive the traffic okay
what your budget is
okay you can basically choose your
audience here
so you're going to be able to choose
what type of
campaign is going to be and based on the
campaign you're going to go ahead and
choose
the kind of audience you want to focus
in on you're going to be able to choose
the location
the age range the gender so all of this
is going to be set up in the ad set
or the campaign or the ad if you go
ahead and edit it out remember
you can do a b testing as well so you
have a lot of different
options and features available to you
right in
ads manager when you're managing your
paid search campaigns on facebook
so if you want some more information
about all the different features
and tools and facebook ads manager check
out the facebook ads tutorial
2019 uh webinar that we did earlier this
year
in addition you can also look at another
one that we did on facebook called
facebook advertising tips
and strategies so that should give you
some sense of
everything related to facebook ads and
how to take advantage of the facebook
ads manager platform
so if there's anything on social that we
may have missed
or that you use feel free to add a
comment below the video we'd love to
hear your feedback
okay let's talk about some affiliate
marketing tools let's turn our attention
affiliate marketing
a lot of affiliate marketing platforms
out there
the number one probably is commission
junction
also known as cj they're an affiliate
platform
they having a freemium model meaning you
can have a free trial
but basically you're gonna have to move
on and pay for the platform
likewise for house offers you have
volume you
really when it comes to affiliate
marketing a lot of platforms out there
click inc hey when so a lot of these are
brokers per se and when i say brokers
like for example with cj
you as a merchant or you as a publisher
can get in touch with a merchant you as
a merchant can get in touch with a
publisher
meaning cj helps bridge the gap between
you
finding somebody to build your network
with okay
so that's what really affiliate
marketing is and you
really need a platform to kind of put it
all together and
it's a lot a lot of affiliate marketing
platforms we're actually going to take a
look at cj and go through some of the
features in the platform here shortly
but let's just take a look
at why we need these affiliate marketing
tools well
these affiliate marketing tools identify
you know affiliates inflowers
employees other advocates you want to
partner with so again
you could be on the merchant side you
could be actually selling a product
and you're going to want somebody to
help you sell that product somebody with
a website who's an influencer who drives
a lot of traffic to their own site
who you know does sell reputable brand
etc so you need somebody to help you
introduce you to these sites okay so cj
and some of these other
marketing platforms affiliate marketing
platforms do that
okay so these tools are there to
do the introductions the brokering the
relationship
so the other benefit here is you can
contract with affiliates and track the
traffic and conversions well what do i
mean by that
well if you do use cj.com by no means am
i
only endorsing that platform there are
plenty others out there
but whatever platform you use you're
gonna want to be able to
set up terms and conditions with that
particular affiliate
so you could set up with terms and
conditions for say 10
off all sales as an example okay well
you're gonna need a platform that will
help you
broker that contract okay contract terms
or
program terms furthermore you're gonna
need a platform to help you track
hey is this affiliate helping me drive
traffic
or is this affiliate driving traffic to
my products
and this is affiliate helping me sell so
these platforms help you do just that
okay so
you can gain high website rankings with
the help of your affiliate
meaning that hey your affiliate can be
promoting your product and if they're
promoting your product
you have a chance to show up via paid
search organic search
off other websites so social
so you have a lot of benefits to
working with affiliate marketing in
itself and the tools available
will help you gain website rankings as
one example we want to be
able to track certain metrics okay so an
affiliate marketing you have earnings
per click
epc as an example most platforms
measure epc from a seven day period to a
three month period
okay you can also figure out what the
actual cost per click is
just like you do on say google search
you can actually measure that in
affiliate okay you want to eliminate
fraudulent clicks impressions and
conversions so
any affiliate platform worth its weight
is going to help you
understand you know how many impressions
and clicks and conversions you're
getting and help you manage that in
terms of
fraudulent clicks or hey if you're
getting a lot of impressions and no
clicks that's a problem too
so these platforms are really built on
helping you manage your relationship
with the affiliate
by offering up all sorts of reports and
tools
you know the other big benefit here to
affiliate marketing tool is hey
we can influence our customers
throughout their buying journey so
we could set up different promotions
based on
hey did somebody go to the website did
somebody see our product does somebody
click on our product did somebody
go into the shopping cart with our
product did somebody purchase
our product so there's all sorts of
steps in the funnel so to speak and hey
you can work with an affiliate
a publisher to influence your customers
throughout that
purchasing funnel throughout that
journey so let's go ahead and log in
here
so when you log in like any other
digital marketing tool
any other platform you're gonna have
your own settings and whatnot
so really the whole idea behind any
affiliate marketing tool
is really there to manage your
publishers
who do you want as a publisher who do
you want selling your product
you obviously want somebody who's
relevant somebody who's going to be able
to sell a product somebody who has a
targeted audience that's similar to
yours
okay so we go into cj.com we're going to
log
in and here you can see a publisher's
link so we're going to click on the
publishers link
and remember when you sign up publishers
you have to have program terms and so if
we click on publishers
program terms we're going to be able to
see
all the different program terms
available so here we could see
the different program terms we have set
up for certain publishers
so we just click on that we'll be able
to see that's the default program term
so remember
you could set up your own program term
for any
publisher so as a best practice if you
have publishers who are actually
performing
well who are selling your products maybe
you want to offer them a little bit more
on the commission side
maybe you want to sweeten the deal maybe
you know these guys
these publishers get better program
terms versus say other publishers who
don't
and so here we can see the program terms
basically
you could see what the terms are the
action and the different policies here
so everything you need to do to manage
that publisher in terms of payment
is done under the program terms now if
the program terms are met
the publisher actually sells your
products cj
is the broker they're the ones who are
going to initiate the payment
based on the program terms so be careful
on the program terms
you want to be able to set them
appropriately cj has templates
cj has some default program terms that
you can use
and offer up to different publishers so
based on the program terms that's how
your publishers are going to get paid
and so here you can have as many
different program terms as you want
there's no limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again
based on performance and so here we can
see
what publishers are under what program
terms
so again if your publisher is performing
well
sweeten the deal offer them a better
program terms
and so you can align publishers with
different
program terms and so that's the whole
idea behind
program terms is you want to be able to
align publishers with that so when you
sign up a publisher
they're going to get a line with a
program term meaning
what are they going to get paid for
selling your product
now if we want to manage by status
instead of by program terms
we could see all the different
organizations we have
in our network these are our publishers
we're the affiliate we're the ones
selling the product
we want to know who's selling who's not
selling
and so we can look at all our publishers
by program
terms or by status okay so
basically you can see here the term
status whether it's active or not
earnings basically what they've sold
over the last
basically seven days or three months so
you could look at
basically how your publishers are
performing
just by clicking on manage by status
here
in cg.com so when you're looking at
reports
in cj.com or really any other affiliate
program
you might see the acronym epc
this stands for earnings per click
actually
it's a little misleading it's actually
earnings per
100 clicks so basically cj
calculates you know how much your
publisher is actually making per click
you know just like paid search we're
paying google x amount per click
it's the same thing here we can't or
these publishers can't make any money
if they don't generate clicks so that's
why you have an epc
model or metric so to speak so you can
measure
earnings per click cj does it over seven
day period
and over a three month period so you
could sort
based on seven day or three month to see
who's earning the most
per click in terms of publishers now you
can select
under publishers groups now you can
group your publishers
okay so if you have say a group of
publishers in a specific region
like the united states or india or if
you're just focused on the united states
and say you have publishers in different
states like texas
california missouri arkansas well you
can group
those publishers into different groups
and
you can look at your different group
names here so
here we could see canada and so we have
our publishers
grouped into a group called canada
why because they're based in canada
makes sense so you want
to be able to organize your publishers
because the whole idea behind affiliate
marketing cj is you want to be able to
get the best publishers available for
your network
and so as you get more publishers for
your network
you'll be able to basically start
grouping them where it makes sense now
the example i gave you is by geography
you could do by geography or you could
do
by publisher status meaning my best
performing publishers go into a group
if they're in a group then they get a
aligned with a certain
program term so you could group
your publishers any way you want by
status meaning they're selling more
these are our best performing publishers
or
by region or you know by promotion
i mean how you group your publishers is
totally up to you
however take advantage of the option to
create publisher groups because
the whole idea again i'm gonna repeat it
is you want to get publishers you want
to start
building your base of publishers because
the more publishers you have
the more chance you are to sell your
product
remember if nobody clicks on your
product then nobody's going to buy your
product so
if you have publishers who are promoting
your product for you
then you have a good opportunity to sell
it so the more publishers you have on
board the better the opportunity so
now once you have publishers you can
start grouping these publishers
accordingly to whatever makes sense the
business decision
just know the options available in cj to
group publishers
let's turn our attention to social media
marketing tools
social media always a great topic to
talk about
so we're going to finish up all our
digital marketing tools with social
media
we talked about seo paid competition
affiliate email you know web analytics
it's just appropriate to finish up with
social media because social media has
so many tools available so many
okay the first one i can think about
here is hootsuite
hootsuite is a great social media
marketing tool to use
okay it's a freemium okay you can set up
a free trial here
you you basically a base account and
then
uh you can use hootsuite to do a lot of
things
anything from setting up landing pages
to actually publishing
content to listening hootsuite to me
is one of the most powerful social media
marketing tools available
you got buffer buffer is a paid version
but you can actually
set up a low cost or free account
actually on buffer
and then move to a paid account okay you
got tweetdeck it's been around a long
time that is actually free
and i would recommend tweetdeck and
we're gonna take a look at that here in
a couple minutes
okay and then you got sprout social
sprout social is another social
marketing platform
similar to hootsuite do a lot of
reporting
a lot of publishing you can a lot of
listening and so we're going to take a
look at sprout chelsea today as well
before we do that let's go over why
these tools are important to us from a
social media perspective
you're pumping out a lot of content so
you need to be able to
smartly efficiently you know schedule
and manage your post
okay so you're not just working likely
with just
one platform like facebook you're
probably on a number of different
platforms
depending on your business depending on
your bandwidth depending on what you're
selling your products etc
your audience obviously has a lot to do
with it you know it could be instagram
pinterest you want to be able to
consolidate all that
and manage it in one place and that's
what social media marketing tools do
they allow you to manage everything in
one place
so if you could manage everything in one
place then these social media marketing
platforms need to be able to make it
easy for you to add
and manage different accounts okay so a
lot of them
have the ability for you to add you know
not just one twitter account but
multiple twitter accounts
and not just one social media platform
but multiple
social media platforms and a good social
media marketing so worth its weight
will help you monitor the results so
monitor social media posts that help
drive leads and sales
in other words you're going to have a
lot of different metrics associated with
each social media
marketing platform okay which one is
actually doing its job
okay so you want to be able to easily
manage these platforms applications
and websites very efficiently okay so
instead of having to log
into each platform is log into one place
get a sense of what's been posted what
the engagement is
did they purchase etc and what you want
to do is be
able to individually customize every
social media post across different
platforms so
it just makes it a lot easier to do that
in the social media marketing tools okay
you don't want to send out a blanket
message across different platforms you
want to be able to
go ahead and customize a post
depending on what that post is depending
on what the product is what time of day
what target market what target audience
so customization is a lot
easier using these social media
marketing tools you want to be able to
engage with brand advocates so
listening is a good thing with social
media marketing tools using the
listening functionality so you can
actually see
who is a brand advocate who's not a
brand advocate who's an influencer who's
not an influencer
and then of course you want to analyze
the behavior of your audience and
optimize
individual post on real-time data so if
for example you post something using one
of these social media marketing
platforms
and you see it go viral then you want to
be able to react to that
in real time so you're going to be able
to see that in real time on these
social media marketing tools these
platforms like sprout social and
hootsuite
and then you're going to be able to
react to that behavior and then of
course
monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key
we always want to monitor conversions
based on our kpis
our business goals so there are also a
few important digital marketing tools
that can help you in different ways
okay so without further ado let's jump
in and take a look
at what's available in terms of social
media marketing
so just a quick reminder if you are
running ads on facebook or you're
posting on facebook as an example or any
platform in general that platform's
going to have
its own metrics if you will so for
example facebook
has something called facebook inside so
you'll be able to actually see
you know what's been posted based on you
know the last seven days in this example
how many page views you're getting
engagements recent posts so
just to let you know yes you can go into
any one of these platforms on its own
and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
facebook ads okay you can go
right into facebook ads manager and view
data there okay so the whole point here
though
on using a social media tool is that you
can
measure all that in one place so if we
log into sprout social
i can set up these accounts right into
sprout social so i don't have to log
into twitter individually or
facebook into individually i can link
them up all within sprout
social and then i can go to reports just
like i can with facebook insights
and then once i'm in facebook excuse me
once i'm in sprout social
reporting then i can go ahead just like
i can in facebook insights except it's
all right here for me i can jump into
you know facebook and dig a little bit
deeper as to what's going on
with my account so i don't have to log
into facebook directly i can see you
know the impressions the engagement the
clicks
over a period of time i can see my
audience growth
i can see my publishing behavior how
often my publishing
i can see the top post individually i
could see impressions by day
you know a lot of this same material
same information
is already in facebook insights so if
it's available on facebook insights
you know you're definitely going to have
it available in a tool like sprout
social so you want to be able to just
efficiently log in
and jump from one platform to the other
so here you know i can go to instagram
you know and look at instagram data or i
can look at twitter information
so you want to be able to efficiently
jump
from one platform to the other using
in this example sprout social now as i
mentioned as part of one of the benefits
of a social media tool is that
you can publish content you want to be
able to publish content because
you want to be able to organize and
schedule accordingly you don't want to
be
submitting and publishing content right
after one another okay you want to be
able to spread it out
efficiently and effectively and so here
we could see
you know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is click compose select a profile
write whatever we need to do you can
schedule it for tomorrow
at a specific time and there you go
voila
scheduled so this is on twitter okay so
you know we could choose another
platform here it's just that easy to
schedule
so you want to be able to schedule
accordingly because
again when you schedule something then
you want to look at the behavior of it
so it's just as simple as going from
publishing
to reporting and then based on when
something got published you could see
the reaction of it and react to it
so another thing here that i like about
it's about social hootsuite a lot of
these other platforms do it really well
you got listening tools so you can
listen
in on conversations that are being had
for example
uh mail delivery you know if we do mail
delivery and twitter search we'll be
able to see
what's been tweeted about mail
deliveries you know if that's the
business we're in we can
refine our search and choose a specific
location a radius to hone in
if we're local okay so this is sprout
social's example of listening
here let's take a look at another
example i'm in later.com
so later very similar spot social and
that it does
a lot of the same things you can
actually schedule
content on a particular platform and one
thing i like about later here you can
actually
see it visually you can see calendar and
what's been scheduled
so i could see today i have scheduled
something scheduled at 1 15
local time and again i have five
profiles set up for this account
so i can pick and choose the profile
that i want to publish to
so it just makes it that much easier and
i can visually see it
and that's important so here i can click
on media library so the one thing about
later.com is that
you know you have a library of images
that potentially you can reuse
so if i click on this image here okay i
can get a sense of
when it was used and i can view it on a
calendar i can add label for it
so that's another benefit to later is
that they have this media library here
they have conversations so i can
actually connect
to a platform and listen in on
conversations that are being had
similar to the listening tool in sprout
social and
they have analytics so you can actually
see
right in later.com how your particular
social media platform is performing
so i can see it here over seven days i
can see the number of followers have
increased
i can see the growth rate i can see the
number of impressions
that i've received okay so i want to be
able to see
how my particular platform is performing
over a period of time so i can look at
reach
the la profile views website clicks okay
so i can get a lot of good insights here
right in the analytics platform later
you can look at specific post
performance so
if we posted something i could see
basically how many
likes it received how many comments
impressions
the reach and then if i wanted to i can
click on details and get
more specific information on it
engagement rate
okay discovery actions comments
saves etc so later.com goes into
some nice detail about post performance
they even have date on hashtags so if
you use a hashtag
you can actually see how many times the
hashtag's been
used or saved how many impressions it's
received okay
so they really go into some nice detail
here
about how your post and how your
accounts are performing
and here's a tool i really like i've
been using for a long time
and that's tweetdeck so what tweetdeck
does is connect with your twitter
account
so you can see in a different visual so
to speak
of how your twitter account looks in
terms of your feed
here i can see this is my feed here okay
i can see some notifications i can see
specific messages
then on this column i can see activity
okay so i can add different columns here
if i wanted to
and basically by adding columns you can
see i can look for
what's trending as an example so i'm
going to add in a column that says
trending
and so now i can go in and see okay
these are all the different
things that are trending on twitter so
you can actually
add a column and pay attention to
something really specific
okay so for example search okay so right
now i have men's health but
i could type in let's just say world cup
okay so i could see the you got the
cricket world cup
you got you know the soccer football
world cup going on
so you know we could pick a particular
topic
to follow if we wanted to so again here
i'm following men's health so i can now
see you know everything that's been
posted on
men's health now if i click on for
example
one of these hashtags here that's
trending i can actually see
who's tagging or using that friday
feeling
in their tweets and so the whole idea
behind
you know tweetdeck it serves up a
interesting
overview so to speak of not only your
account
but you know a specific topic or what's
trending
or you know other things that are being
said
so if you really want to pay attention
to your brand or something really
specific like
you know your competitors or a specific
product then you can just do a search on
that
and so that's the great thing about
tweak deck it allows you to kind of just
look and listen in on everything going
on
in twitter now we do have a good video
out here on youtube
how to start social media marketing so
if you haven't had a chance to look at
it take a look
it goes over some of these tools that we
cover today like sprout social
later.com you know facebook insights so
it does cover
in more detail some of what we covered
on these social media marketing tools
so take a look at how to start social
media marketing
so we covered a lot of different
marketing tools digital marketing tools
everything from seo to email
to social to paid to affiliate
competitor but there's also a few other
digital marketing tools that you can use
in different ways like video seo for
example
so vid iq you know we want to use vid iq
to get a good sense of how a particular
video is performing
so here if we go into youtube you can
see vid iq
is a browser extension or browser
a plug-in if you will so i can go and
take a look
at a specific specific video and see how
many hours it's been watched how many
views
minutes watch subscribers etc you know
the great thing here i can look at the
entire
entire account so i can get good
insights
into my video or my entire account here
just by adding in the vid iq extension
into my chrome browser so vid iq
actually does give you some
really really good insights into
not only your account but the video and
so recommend vid iq because it's good
for
video seo okay there's also tools
related to
content optimization so you know if
you're doing seo
and you have a lot of content on your
site well you know what
we want to be able to use a tool maybe a
third party tool to give some objective
reasoning
as to what more we can be doing so you
got tools like seo site checkup or
site analyzer these are pay tools but
you know if you're really heavily
invested in seo
then they may pay dividends for you you
want to be able to
make sure your content is fully
optimized
to the fullest according to you know
google's algorithms and so
you maybe you know want to invest in
that third-party tool so these are good
tools to use for content optimization
you know there's also other key reddit
but you know there's keyword planner
uh in google there's also a word stream
there's a lot of different keyword tools
out there so
you may not have a google ads platform
and so if you don't have google ads then
you may not be able to gain access to
google's keyword planner so
having a third party keyword tool
will pay dividends as well because those
dividends pay off in the form of not
only pay-per-click
but also seo and if you're heavily
invested in content
heavily invested in social then you may
want to take a look at
the keyword tool keyword it and it's
primarily used for
reddit we talk about page load time so
we looked at that
in google analytics we know that it
heavily impacts
seo so there are other tools available
you got a third-party tool here that's
free
solarwinds pingdom you actually have
pagespeed insights by google
so these are free tools that you could
take advantage of
and determining how you can improve your
page load time
my favorite topic conversion rate
optimization
so you got a couple in here crazy egg
and target okay so i'm going to show you
another tool called hot
so here if you log into hotjar.com you
can set up an account
it's actually free and with a free
account you can
have hotjar measure the heat map
not only the heat map but the click
mapping the scrolling of a particular
page
and so here you can see we're looking at
a particular page here
so hotjar allows me to you know see
on that page where people are clicking
um i can also see where people are
moving
i can also see you know the scrolling of
a particular page
okay so you can see here on the page i
can see people are moving over here to
the right
that's where they're clicking mostly if
i switch over to move mode then i can
see
on that particular page where people are
actually
moving their mouse and then i have my
scroll analysis
so i could see you know how far down
people actually scrolling the page
and so again with a paid account you can
measure up to ten thousand page views
with the free version
you can measure up to two thousand pages
and so two thousand page use
allows you to get some insight as to
what people are
clicking on or where they're moving or
how they're scrolling on a particular
page
and so i definitely recommend hot jar
they also do funneling they also do
forms
polls lots of other tools available in
hotjar so hotjar.com is a tool
i would recommend as well so one final
tool
and i'd be remiss if i didn't mention it
and that's google optimized so google
optimize
is a google platform that allows you to
a b
test and so a b testing means that you
have an original page
and you're changing one element on that
page
to see which one performs better and so
with google optimize it's just
very easy to set up to run
and the whole point of google optimize
and a b testing is to improve website
performance so
here you can see i have an account set
up and optimize you can see we're
running
one test here and we're just testing one
element
versus the original so we move photos to
the top of the page
the original didn't have the photos to
the top of the page
and so we can go into reporting here
google optimize does all the heavy
lifting
and so here you could see we can look at
bounces or we can look
at you know basically a measure the test
up against the metric that's important
to our business
and again the whole point is to improve
website performance
and so definitely take a look at google
optimize
we'll have another webinar in the future
on the topic but
you know to me google optimize is free
you can run up to five
tests okay and if you can run up to five
different tests and that means you have
the ability
to really improve website performance
okay so google optimize is a tool
that i would recommend okay so we could
probably go on for a few more hours on
all the different
various types of digital marketing tools
that are out there on the internet
we covered a lot of them from paid to
email to social
a lot of them are free a lot of them are
paid versions in between you got
freemium so
go out there experiment have fun play
around
if you have a tool we didn't cover that
you feel our audience should know about
then go ahead and put them in the
comments section under this video
thanks for hanging in there covered a
lot of good information today i want to
thank you for paying attention if you
have any more information
please visit us at simplylearn.com thank
you